they're fighting a war here and they're
losing it was the moment the reality of
the pandemic hit home
sky's chief correspondent stuart
ramsey's extraordinary eyewitness
reporting
from bergamo in italy europe's epicenter
providing the first terrifying insight
of what covert could do
and it seems you either live and recover
or you die
it won the award for international news
coverage one of four victories for sky
news at
royal television society awards
including
for a fourth year in a row the news
channel of the year
once again is sky news
the virtual nature of the ceremony
reflected the story that dominated last
year's headlines
and kovid similarly dominated the awards
sky's reporting of the pandemic here in
the uk
winning best home news coverage gives
you a reality shot
of just how serious this is while people
and politics correspondent nick martin
was named specialist journalist of the
year for bringing to life the human cost
of coronavirus in care homes i'll tell
you what they fought
so hard to keep their residents alive
they saved many of them
but an awful lot died and my thoughts
are with all the families who've lost
what loved ones in this pandemic
technical teams across the industry
including from sky news were also given
this year's judges award
for how they've adapted to the pandemic
keeping us
on air when trusted impartial news
matters more than ever
and the outstanding contribution award
went to the head of sky news john riley
who the judges said has affected genuine
change in our business
accepting the award he issued a rallying
cry for further
innovation luck in television journalism
still too often favors the white and
middle class
young people from ethnic minorities need
far more than only luck to succeed
they need advice support and opportunity
to get on in our trade
and they need our respect respect for
the new ideas and new skills they can
offer us
so please give it to them the awards
underlining the importance of news in an
extraordinary year
annabotting sky news